kevin is with us in North Carolina
hi Kevin how are you I'm fine thanks
that thanks for talking to me sure
what's up a question for you I am I'm
considering a career change and I may
either change professions altogether and
or you know cut my hours to part-time
and I'm 49 and I have a million dollars
in my retirement accounts and about six
hundred thousand in my taxable account
and I'm wondering I maxed out my my
retirements my my TSP every year and I'm
wondering is it in light of my my
situation be kind of being in flux did
it make sense to cut back on my
retirement contributions and put that
money into my individual taxable account
to kind of give me more protection in
case you know I need the money
again it doesn't give me more protection
but gives you access for the next ten
yeah yeah and so I mean you've already
got a million in retirement and so you
know at 49 and so you'll have three
million in that account if you've got it
invested well by the time you get to
sixty-five if you had nothing to it okay
if that's invested in good gross stock
mutual funds it'll double about it or
seven years or so and so you know and so
you know you got 15 years 14 years 64
years old you have around 3 million if
you add nothing else to it yeah I
probably would go heavy into the
non-taxable and then you've got some
investing you can do or if you're your
next career is a business situation
where you want to buy into something you
want to start something with some
capital either one you've got access to
it to do that and so yeah you've done
very very well did you inherit any of
this money or did you make it all maiden
I mean the vast majority of it my dad
died many years ago and he left me a
little bit but 90% of it is themself
generated Wow what you do for later all
the read all the retirement I'm sorry
what'd you do how'd you make it I'm at
aegis just frugal living and constant
investing over the years okay with my
retirement account and probably 90% of
my individual my taxable account all of
the retirement account was was self
generated but the about 90% of my
individual account has been was my own
money so it's okay frugal living like
he'd like you like you advise here and
what did you what was your what was your
first career teaching you're a teacher
in college a public school or what no
public school I did some international
teaching but mostly public school Wow
and you just you've just been really
frugal in and in a heavy investor then
yeah but I've also I've also lived my
life you know people people kind of ate
they they kind of accuse me of being a
miser and you know I donate and I donate
more to charity than most people
probably in the world do not that I'm
some kind of hero but you know I donate
a lot of money to charity every year and
I've lived abroad I've travelled a lot
so it can be done you know yeah you just
watched what you were doing and didn't
have a lot of setbacks and mistakes and
you know your intentional with every one
of those dollars well way to go man you
totally and every day millionaire
congratulations yeah I think you're on
track there I think you're got enough in
retirement to where you're going to be
okay and because what we're saying is
you're probably going to end up if
things just kind of stay on course
between 65 and 70 you'll probably be
worth about 10 million somewhere in
there and if three or four million of
that is retirement then that's going to
be okay you're not gonna be too heavy
and you're gonna have had a lot of other
opportunities because also I mean if you
start being very careful and like
started a business or started doing some
investing like in some real estate or
something where you watch it you know
what you're doing and you're a hundred
percent cash no borrowing you could take
that six hundred and it do actually
better and you reach a point that money
is more flexible and you can make more
with it than you might have in just a
standard investment process so a good
question man thanks for the call